Bonjour, zesteux et zesteurs !
Observez toutes cespetites cellules imbriquées qui s'affairent à
communiquer pour produire un embryon. Des
images à couper le souffle !
Des chercheurs aux interfaces entre l'informatique et la biologieont collaboré pour développer de nouveaux outils.
Et ça, pour permettre de percer les secrets
de la communication des cellules embryonnaires,
entre cris et chuchotements. A votre avis, comment
on passe d'un œuf fécondé à un animal tout bien
formé ? Car si vous saviez déjà comment on fait
les bébés, aujourd'hui on va découvrir comment
ils se forment ! Eh bien, cette prouesse, on la doit
aux cellules embryonnaires, qui s'organisent à
toute vitesse pour croître, se diviser et se
transformer en cellules de peau, de cerveau... Et
ça, jusqu'à obtenir un être entier, avec chaque
tissu au bon endroit, pas comme sur un tableau
cubiste, par exemple.
Et pour s'organiser, les cellules embryonnaires communiquent entre elles.
On pourrait croire que c'est un monde mystérieux et
silencieux, mais je peux vous dire que là-dedans,
c'est toute une cacophonie ! Mais chut !
Pour s'organiser, les cellules s'envoient parfois des signaux chimiques
à longue distance, un peu comme si elles se
criaient des informations pour croitre, se
diviser, s'organiser, dans ce joli ballet qu'est le
développement embryonnaire. Ça, les scientifiques le
savaient et l'observaient déjà depuis un certain
moment, jusqu'à ce que l'arrivée de nouveaux
outils bouleverse nos connaissances à ce sujet.
Les chercheurs ont développé un logiciel nommé
ASTEC pour digitaliser des images de cellules
et modéliser leurs formes et leurs contacts, mais
pour les visualiser et les partager, un nouvel
outil manquaient à l'appel. Alors en fusionnant
leurs compétences en informatique et
en biologie, les chercheurs ont créé...
MORPHONET ; un logiciel navigateur de forme au service de
la biologie, offrant la possibilité d'étudier
des objets biologiques 3D à différentes échelles,
de l'ADN à l'anatomie.
Et qui dit nouvel outil
de techniques d'imagerie dans le domaine du
vivant, dit nouvelles découvertes ! Et d'ailleurs,
connaissez-vous les ascidies ?
-Quoi ?
-Les ascidies!
Et rien à voir avec les Jackson Five !
-Les qui ?
Les Jackson Five ! *toutoutoutoutouuuu* ACD *nanana* one two three !
Une ascidie est un animal marin invertébré,
et les scientifiquessont taquins puisqu'ils l'ont nommée Phallusia mammillata,
littéralement : "le phallus avec desmamelles". Et c'est la chouchoute des chercheurs, car
elle se reproduit toute l'année, la petite coquine,
et elle possède l'avantage d'avoir des embryons
très transparents, et donc idéaux à observer.
Ah, tiens, regardez, revoilà nos dix embryons!
Toutes les deux minutes, et pendant huit heures,
les scientifiques ont enregistré les images du
développement de 10 embryons d'ascidie, grâce à un
microscope à feuilles de lumière. Avec l'ASTEC,
on passe de ces images un modèle 3D que l'on
peut comparer à un genre de réalité virtuelle,
et chaque petite brique de couleur que l'onvoit ici représente une cellule embryonnaire
qui formera un même tissu : cerveau, peau, muscle, etc.
Avec l'arrivée de MORPHONET, on a pu
explorer ces modèles 3D sous toutes leurs coutures, les éclater, les décortiquer pour en comprendre les
moindres mécanisme en rentrant dans l'invisible.
MORPHONET nous permet aussi d'observer et suivre
automatiquement chaque cellule, sa position, ses
contacts et ses progénitures quand elle se divise.
En gros, ce logiciel nous transforme en agents de
la CIA microscopiques. Attendez, on va faire une
petite pause, là. Vous voyez ça, là ? Mais regardez!
Les embryons se ressemblent comme deux gouttes
d'eau, et ça au même moment, comme si les cellules
étaient synchronisées et collées entre elles, et ça
c'est assez inhabituel pour des embryons d'animaux,
dont les cellules embryonnaires gigotent d'habitude
beaucoup plus. Les scientifiques se sont rendus
compte que cette propriété était propre à une
poignée de groupes, dont les ascidies. Ici, les
cellules n'ont pas besoin de crier pour s'agencer,
la mécanique est différente : chacune tient sa place,
se divise et se spécialise en restant proche
de ses voisines. Les chercheurs ont donc émis la
possibilité d'un mode de communication non plus
à longue distance, mais beaucoup plus discret. Pour
résumer, ici, on se chuchote les informations,
en s'effleurant. Tout est plus intime, plus calme, plus
suave ! On se laisse aller, on touche ses voisines
et... Je... Pardon...
En plus de nous apprendre toutes cesdécouvertes, ASTEC et MORPHONET nous chuchotent à
quel point il est important d'avoir de nouveaux
outils à partager dans la recherche, et comment
la synergie entre les domaines peut mener à de
nouvelles découvertes incroyables. MORPHONET c'est
une nouvelle façon de voir, mais aussi de partager
le vivant, et pas que sur des ascidies, mais plein
d'autres éléments. C'est également un navigateur en
ligne, un peu comme une immense banque de données
biologiques 3D, via laquelle on peut recréer
des événements biologiques par ordinateur, et
sans forcément avoir à manipuler le vivant, via
des animaux par exemple. Bref, MORPHONET c'est...
MORPHONET, c'est la vie, hasta la vista, baby !
Alors, avouez, ça valait le coup de rester jusqu'au
bout pour découvrir tout ça, non ? Et puis, en plus,
je suis certaine qu'après avoir visionné cet
épisode, vous allez vous précipiter pour crier sur
tous les toits toutes ces connaissances autour de
vous ! Ou alors, peut-être simplement les chuchoter.
Dans tous les cas, abonne-toi, sinon, I'll be back !